[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il y a dix ans j'ai quitté mon travail
de libraires j'ai fait ma valise et je
suis parti vivre à los angeles
je ne connaissais personne là bas mais
je savais que je voulais faire des films
alors ça me paraissait logique d'aller à
hollywood
au bout de quelques années je suis
rentré en france
quand je rencontrais des gens et qu'ils
me demandaient qu'est ce que tu fais
dans la vie je leur disais je suis
réalisatrice je fais des films et
d'ailleurs je reviens de quelques années
à los angeles
souvent à ce moment là je voyais un
petit une petite lumière dans leurs yeux
il me disait mémé c'est génial
quel genre de film tu fais est ce qu'on
peut les voir au cinéma tu as travaillé
avec des gens connus et moi je leur
répondais je fais de la fiction on peut
pas voir mes films au cinéma pas encore
et en fait non non j'ai pas travailler
avec des gens connus à ce moment là il y
avait un blanc le temps que leur
enthousiasme redescendre d'un cran
et puis on se mettait à parler de los
angeles
peu à peu à force de voir le regard des
gens passer de curieux a déçu lorsqu'il
se rendait compte que j'ai été une
saltimbanque
je me suis mise à mentir sur ce que je
faisais je ne disais plus je suis
réalisatrice je disais je suis free
lance et je ne disais plus je fais des
films je disais je fais des vidéos pour
des clients alors ça faisait moins rêver
mais c'était utile concret on se mettait
à parler prospection facturation
équipements et surtout je n'avais pas
l'impression de devoir m'excuser de
n'avoir pas réussi ça va quand même mis
un petit peu la puce à l'oreille je me
suis dit mais pourquoi est-ce que tu
mens sur le métier que tu fais et
surtout pourquoi est ce que tu te sens
obligé de diminuer les attentes des gens
pour ne pas qu'il pense que tu as échoué
et c'est à ce moment là que j'ai
vraiment commencé à m'intéresser à la
notion de succès et à la façon dont
celle ci a évolué ces dernières années
notamment avec l'arrivée dès réseaux
sociaux dans nos vies qui nous rappelle
au quotidien où on se situe sur la
courbe de la réussite par rapport aux
autres
8 milliard d'habitants ce classement sur
la courbe de la réussite c'est ce qui
fait que parfois lorsque l'on parle avec
des gens il ya un petit concours de la
personne qui leur a le plus d'impact qui
se met en place
ça passe par des petits mots je connais
telle personne j'ai tant de gens qui me
suivent
j'ai visité et en deux pays j'ai été
speaker à tel événement le tête c'est
bien pour le concours d'un pacte merci
ted
le pouvoir est le succès ont toujours
existé et ils ont toujours été des
moteurs pour certaines personnes et des
obstacles pour d'autres mais ces
dernières années les choses ont pris une
ampleur telle que moi je me suis déjà
retrouvé à discuter avec des jeunes de
24 ans qui m'expliquait qu'il avait
abandonné un rêve ou une idée avant même
d'avoir commencé
et la raison pour laquelle il avait
abandonné avant même d'avoir essayé
c'est qu'ils étaient paralysés par le
succès de gens plus jeunes qu'eux qui le
voyait au quotidien sur les réseaux
sociaux
j'ai déjà écouté des jeunes de 24 ans
m'affirmer que s'il avait vraiment eu
quelque chose à faire sur cette planète
il aurait déjà dû avoir percé à 24 ans
il ne se sentait pas vieux il se sentait
périmés on a développé un rapport
étonnant avec ce que l'on pourrait
appeler notre date de péremption
avant on en avait une et c'était la date
de notre mort aujourd'hui on a une
deuxième date de péremption dans nos
vies et c'est la date de notre
péremption sociale cette idée que la
valeur de ce que l'on fait doit être
reconnue et quantifiables et si on n'a
pas un retour immédiat et positif sur ce
que l'on fait ou pire si ce que l'on
fait
est reconnu comme inutile risible ou
ratés alors on se sent socialement
périmés et c'est comme ça que des jeunes
de 24 ans préfère aller s'asseoir sur le
banc de touche et regardez l'histoire se
faire sans eux
plutôt que de risquer de faire quelque
chose et de ne pas recevoir de retour
immédiat est positif en m'intéressant à
cette nouvelle notion du succès et à
notre date de péremption sociale moi je
me suis rendu compte qu'en fait mon
travail ce n'est pas d'écrire des
scénarios ou de réaliser des films
mon travail c'est de fabriquer des
histoires
alors c'est un métier qui peut sembler
inutile et pourtant fabriquer des
histoires c'est la meilleure façon que
nous les êtres humains on a trouvé pour
survivre ce soir si on est tous passés
les uns après les autres pour vous
parler pendant 15 minutes
c'est bien parce que la meilleure façon
de faire passer une idée c'est de le
faire à travers une histoire en 2018 on
aurait pu créer un pdf avec l'idée forte
de chaque tête toc résumé en une phrase
et vous l'envoyer par email
vraiment on aurait pu le faire mais ça
vous aurait coûté moins cher
d'ailleurs et ça nous aurait pris moins
de temps mais la puissance des messages
que l'on essaye de faire passer ce
serait évaporé nous le savons et vous le
savez c'est pour ça que vous êtes là
pour écouter des histoires qui vont
ouvrir votre champ des possibles en 1944
les professeurs fritz haider et marianne
simmel ont effectué un test
ils ont montré une vidéo un groupe
d'étudiantes et leur en demander de
répondre à une série de questions pour
décrire ce qu'elle les avait vus alors
moi je vais vous montrer 15 secondes de
cette vidéo
ça valait un petit peu vite mais je vous
invite à essayer de répondre à cette
question qu'est ce que je vois à l'écran
voilà c'était 15 secondes lorsqu'ils ont
dépouillé les questionnaires haider et
s'y mêlent se sont rendus compte que 33
des 34 étudiante avait fabriqué une
histoire elle avait prêté des intentions
des émotions et des comportements aux
figures géométriques qui se déplacent
aléatoirement dans l'espace que vous
venez de voir cette étude a été l'une
des premières études scientifiques a
confirmé que notre cerveau comprend le
monde à travers le prisme des histoires
on ne peut pas s'empêcher de donner du
sens au monde qui nous entoure et pour
donner du sens au monde qui nous entoure
on fabrique des histoires alors en
sachant ça que les histoires sont
essentiels à notre survie et à notre vie
moi j'ai envie de vous raconter une
histoire décalée du succès une
alternative à cette notion qui paralyse
tant de gens aujourd'hui tout à l'heure
je vous ai dit qu'on avait deux dates de
péremption la date de notre mort et la
date de notre péremption social que l'on
se donne de plus en plus tôt ce que je
ne vous ai pas dit c'est qu'un téléphone
est en train de sonner
ce que je ne vous ai pas dit c'est qu'on
a tous un joker on a tous la possibilité
de devenir une bonne histoire
on a tous la possibilité de devenir une
bonne histoire qui va inspirer d'autres
êtres humains et les permettre d'avancer
et il y a un groupe de gens dont le
métier c'est de distribuer des dockers
les fabriques heures d'histoire ça tombe
bien c'est mon métier mon métier c'est
de chasser d'imaginer et de partager des
histoires de personnes au destin
étonnant innovant impactant et qui vont
représenter des idées fortes et en ce
moment on vit une période extrêmement
intéressantes comme les archéologues
on est en train de déterrer des
nouvelles histoires des histoires
différentes des histoires de personnes
qui à leur époque n'avaient souvent pas
reçu de retour immédiat et positif sur
la valeur de ce qu'elle faisait
et qui cinq ans 50 ans entend 200 ans
cinq cents ans après se retrouve sur le
devant de la scène des histoires pour
nous aider nous les nouvelles
générations à mieux comprendre le monde
et a avancé par exemple certains d'entre
vous reconnaîtront peut-être le nom de
giorgino reid
cette designer textile qui en 1971 à
l'âge de 63 ans a décidé que ce qu'elle
voulait vraiment faire s'était sauvé le
phare de sa petite ville qui risquait de
s'écrouler à cause de l'érosion des
falaises alors giardina met en place
tout un système qu'elle brevette elle va
voir les garde-côtes
elle leur présente son projet ils
l'écoutent ils lui disent on va pas
t'empêcher de le faire mais on va pas
t&d en fait
ok aucun problème à l'aide de son époux
et de volontaires pendant 15 ans
georgina va utiliser ses connaissances
et son temps libre
gratuitement pour empêcher que le phare
ne s'écroule et elle va réussir giardina
est morte en 2001 et le phare lui est
toujours là et puis il ya trois ans une
fabrique de l'histoire française
pénélope bagieu a donné un joker à
georgia n'a elle a partagé son histoire
dans un recueil de bande dessinée
consacrée à plusieurs femmes qui avaient
changé leur histoire et parfois le cours
de l'histoire de façon inattendue
c'est grâce à une chose c'est grâce à
une fabrique de l'histoire que deux cent
mille français et moi même avons été
inspirés par gina et sa ténacité à se
battre pour quelque chose qui était
important pour elle même si
officiellement on lui disait que ça ne
l'était pas et jordin a pu devenir une
bonne histoire parce qu'elle était
actrice active de son histoire elle ne
s'est pas contenté de se dire j'aimerais
bien que le phare ne s'écroule pas non
elle a fait ce qu'il fallait pour que le
phare ne s'écroule pas et ce mot faire
c'est l'une des trois étapes pour
pouvoir devenir une bonne histoire
en fait la recette pour devenir une
bonne histoire aller simple elle et elle
tient en trois étapes d'abord il faut
écouter son intuition pour entendre ce
que nous chacun d'entre nous on a
vraiment envie de faire
puis une fois qu'on l'a écouté il faut
avoir le courage de se lancer et faire
une fois qu'on a eu le courage de se
lancer il faut répéter tous les jours il
faut recommencer
alors aujourd'hui on a beaucoup de
pression sur le type de projets qu'on
choisit de faire il faut qu'ils aient un
but
s'ils n'ont pas de but c'est qu'ils ne
sont pas sérieux et s'ils ne sont pas
sérieux c'est qu'ils n'ont pas de valeur
moi je ne suis pas du tout d'accord avec
cette façon de penser
s'il ya une chose que j'ai appris ces
dix dernières années passées à chasser
et à fabriquer des histoires c'est que
la valeur de ce que l'on fait n'est pas
figé dans le temps
la valeur de ce que l'on fait peut avoir
un impact surprenant dans cinq ans dans
50 ans après notre mort ou la mort de
nos arrière-petits-enfants
alors ça ne sert à rien d'essayer de
choisir de faire quelque chose qui aura
un impact immédiat
on peut pas savoir en fait il faut juste
faire et ces trois éléments s'écouter se
lancer et recommencer ils sont
cristallisés dans l'histoire de carmen
herrera karen herrera est né à la havane
en 1915
très jeune elle se rend compte que ce
qu'elle veut vraiment faire c'est
peindre
alors elle peint tous les jours et puis
elle se découvre que son style c'est le
minimalisme abstrait pile à l'époque où
le minimalisme abstrait est en vogue
trop bien elle voit un premier tableau
et puis plus rien elle fait une première
exposition le public la boude
elle tente de trouver des galeries pour
la représenter tout le monde lui dit non
et puis un jour carmen a l'opportunité
de présenter à nouveau son travail et là
le public est au rendez vous on est en
2004 à ce moment là carmen à 89 ans
aujourd'hui carmen à 103 ans ces 14
dernières années elle a vu ses tableaux
être exposées dans les musées les plus
prestigieux du monde pendant 60 ans
carmen herrera à pain tous les jours des
tableaux donc personne ne juge et qu'ils
avaient de la valeur
et puis un jour l'histoire de carmen
herrera s'est aligné avec l'histoire de
l'art et moi si je vous raconte cette
histoire ce n'est pas pour vous dire que
le succès finit toujours par arriver
parce que c'est pas le cas mais c'est
parce que je suis convaincu que carmen
herrera serait encore en train de
peindre
aujourd'hui même si elle n'avait jamais
rencontré son public de son vivant
carmen herrera ne payez pas pour devenir
célèbre elle peignait pas ce que cela
donnait du sens à sa vie
ce n'est pas le succès qui donne du sens
à notre vie mais c'est le fait d'être
dans l'expression de soi
et lorsque l'on est dans l'expression de
soi la date de péremption sociale
disparaît lorsque l'on est dans
l'expression de soi
les échecs comme les succès de vienne
simplement des étapes sur la courbe de
notre croissance personnelle
ce soir ce que j'ai envie de vous
proposer ces de décaler de détourner
votre attention de ceux dont vous n'avez
pas le contrôle on ne peut pas contrôler
la façon dont les gens vont réagir à ce
que l'on fait mais on peut contrôler ce
que l'on fait alors cessons de prêter
attention au retour que la société ne
donne sur la valeur de ce qui donne du
sens à notre vie parce que la valeur de
ce que nous faisons est rarement
mesurable à l'instant t
et surtout la valeur de ce que nous
faisons va évoluer de façon inattendue
avec le temps aujourd'hui lorsque je
rencontre des gens et qu'il me demande
ce que je fais dans la vie je leur
réponds que je suis fabrique 2
d'histoire
alors personne comprend vraiment ce que
ça veut dire mais c'est pas grave parce
que si j'ai l'opportunité de parler un
peu plus longtemps avec les gens ils
comprennent que fabriquer des histoires
c'est ma façon à moi de m'exprimer
pleinement au quotidien en faisant
depuis dix ans je chasse et je fabrique
des histoires que je partage sous la
forme de scénarios de films de parole de
musique de podcasts de dessins ou de bd
parfois je doute
j'ai l'impression que ce que je fais est
complètement inutile
et puis je me souviens que mon intuition
est probablement en train de me
chuchoter quelque chose et qu'il
faudrait que je les écoute
alors je les écoute et je me lance
et surtout je recommence si demain vous
vous réveillez avec l' envie de faire
quelque chose d'inutile
écoutez vous lancez vous et recommencer
parce que c'est en étant acteur actif de
notre histoire que nous deviendrons des
bonnes histoires des histoires que
d'autres êtres humains pourront utiliser
et partager pour avancer faites ce que
vous avez à faire
peu importe si cela a l'air inutile si
c'est important pour vous c'est que cela
vaut la peine d'être fait exprimez vous
et nous les fabriques heures d'histoire
on vous trouvera merci
[Applaudissements]